European Union,
it's sort of like the windows of
politics that slow.
It doesn't work perfectly and sometimes
it just crashes nonetheless.
Let us be honest.
The other alternatives are not much
better.
Ams consistently be more costly at the
beginning of this year.
It seems like the far right was
stackable.
Some political analysts claims that
brexit would be the beginning of the end
for the European Union,
and during this time the international
media was full of words like frexit or
checks it out.
Either this year or skeptic fierro
wasn't a last for long.
Francis elected a brand new president,
Emmanuel Macron,
who stands up for the European Union
like no one else.
The same has happened in other elections
around Europe.
In other words,
the European Union is alive and kicking
at least for the next four years,
but to do,
hold on for just a minute because things
are more complex than what they might
seem.
In fact,
norms.
All EU fans are the same as many of them
don't even share the same opinion on
what the EU should be.
For instance,
the Crohn's stands for a fiscal union
with the same taxes in every country.
Geneva,
Angela Merkel,
nausea into that.
On the other hands that you formed the
Belgium Prime Minister Abe Verhofstadt,
who is now president of the European
Liberal Party,
says that Europe should become a
federation like the United States.
Does everyone agree with that?
Well,
the answer is rather unsurprisingly,
no.
In fact,
the only thing shared by all these
politicians is the fact that the EU is a
good thing,
but now the questions are,
well,
what is the European Union all about?
What should it become?
Is it a federation or a confederation?
Ends?
What are the different models on the
negotiation table?
Well,
today we are going to answer all of
these questions.
Margaret Thatcher was right.
Margaret township is something like
Elvis Presley to euro skeptics for
decades.
This woman who was the British prime
minister in the 19 eighties has it
become the biggest inspiration for many
of the movements that want to end the
European project,
but then again,
reality is seldom simple.
Now,
it is true that Margaret Thatcher was a
big critic of political integration back
in the time the European Union still
didn't exist.
There was just a community of countries
that traded among themselves.
Nevertheless,
during the 19 eighties,
different European governments agreed to
deepen this interview.
Gracious is
when they started talking about a single
currency and you institutions.
All of this culminated in 1992 with the
signing of the master x treaty,
but the question is,
what's it Margaret Thatcher think about
all of this?
Well,
the truth is if we forget about
stereotypes and we actually read her
memoir,
we find quotes like this,
just not dream of some cozy,
isolated existence on the fringes of the
European community.
Our destiny is in Europe as part of the
importantly.
This doesn't mean that that shit was in
total agreements with all the European
politicians.
She just wanted a different model.
Unlike Lucy wanted to United States of
Europe with the capital of Brussels,
she stood for a confederate.
Certainly
we want to see Europe more united and
with a greater sense of common purpose,
but it must be in a way which preserves
the different traditions,
parliamentary powers and sense of
national pride in one's home going,
we've got to explain what's the
difference between a federation and a
confederation.
An example of a federation would be the
United States of America,
Texas and California have their own
legislatures,
their own governments and their own
laws.
Today,
for instance,
marijuana is legal in California,
but illegal in Texas.
However,
if the congress in Washington DC were to
pass a law legalizing cannabis across
the country,
any state law that would contradict the
federal one would be automatic.
We abolished in the confederation that
states have way more autonomy today.
There are actually no confederations in
the world,
not even in Switzerland.
Of course,
in Switzerland,
the different kansans enjoy a loss of
autonomy and different taxes,
but that doesn't mean they are a
confederation.
For instance,
if the parliaments of burner would pass
a law legalizing marijuana,
the rest of the cousins would have to
accept
yes.
Switzerland was a real confederation.
Each of the different assemblies would
have to have a vote to decide whether
they want to keep cannabis legal or not.
So despite what a lot of people say,
Switzerland is clearly a federation and
so now you might be wondering,
well,
what exactly is a Europe then?
Is it a federation or a confederation?
Of course there are lots of people who
stand for the federal model.
In the last few years,
the champion of this idea has been the
president of the Liberals Diva hotstats
that we need to be formed Europe to make
it a real federation capable to act not
only on in the economic field,
but also by establishing the defense
union by establishing a European
investigation capacity.
But let's go back to the facts today.
Despite what it looks like,
national governments have a lot of
autonomy.
For instance,
years ago,
Brussels,
past the directive,
banning smoking in bars.
After that,
each of the member countries have to
vote on their own anti tobacco law,
men's well,
you know what happens?
Well,
Australia and the Czech Republic did not
pass those laws,
and during those years you could smoke
in the cafes of Prague and Vienna Wall
in Berlin and Paris.
It was completely forbidden.
Vat,
which is the main European tax is
different in each country.
In Spain they a 21 percent,
but in hungry they paid 27 percent
times.
In Germany they've got a 19 percent tax.
In other words,
Europe is not a federation,
but it's also not a confederation
either.
It's kind of a federal confederation and
now you're probably wondering,
is this federal confederation model
actually working or do we need to move
ahead with some sort of United States of
Europe
wrong in the European Union?
We all have heard about the many
mistakes this European integration has
made,
but the truth is many of these floors
could have happened in the member states
individually.
As an example.
Let us have a look at the refugee
crisis.
Now.
It is true that Brussels was incapable
of crafting a common policy to give
asylum to all the citizens that are
running away from countries like Syria,
Iraq or Libya.
But let's not lie to ourselves.
The same happens in every single
country.
In Spain,
for example,
the national government did everything
they could to avoid welcoming the
refugees on the other hands.
Madrid city hall did the exact opposite.
City Hall of Madrid will make a
welcoming project so the refugees will
have a place to live.
In other words,
we cannot expect to Brussels to solve
the problems that nation states have
always had in politics.
Such things.
They're simply not possible.
But do you hold on for a moment because
this does not mean the European Union is
perfect either.
In fact,
there are many problems that are endemic
to this incident.
For example,
let's imagine you are a freelance and
living in Hungary and you work for a
company based in Belgium.
Should you include Vat on the invoice
that you said to them?
Well,
according to EU legislation,
you shouldn't because while it's a
service contract,
but each country has its own tax laws
that in many cases contradicts the EU
laws.
But not only that,
what Vat should you include on that
invoice?
The Hungarian one more.
The Belgium one.
All these problems.
Could be solved if there was a common
ground on taxation matters.
Let's many countries don't want to lose
sovereignty on this matter and no one
does make the first step towards.
So as you might imagine from this,
it's pretty hard for important decisions
to move forward.
So the question is,
what could be the solution to this
problem club with different kinds of
members?
Constitution,
they are useful.
They allow politicians and legislators
to know what they can do and what they
can't.
It's sort of like a minimal agreements
this way a government knows what it can
pass as a law and it's a system that has
been proven effective
so
well.
What's the problem?
Well,
old attempts to release a European
constitution have failed in 2005.
Both France and the Netherlands had
referendums where they rejected the
proposal for a European magna Carta
years later,
Brussels politicians,
matt again to write a new version of
this constitution,
these so called Lisbon Treaty.
This was a milder version of the
previously drafted constitution.
That's integration problems persisted,
but truth is that each country has its
own interests and it's hard to get them
all on the same page,
so why not just recognize the
differences,
and this is why the European Commission
has made the European Whitesburg where
they imagined by you've potential
scenarios for you.
One of them would allow each state to
have a different level of integration.
On the other hand,
at the beginning of 2017,
the economist proposed to create a
European Union with different kinds of
memberships of one hand,
there would be a premium member who
would share a common currency,
common fiscal policy and a common
foreign policy.
On another one,
there would be a silver member would
just share a common market and the free
movement area.
Other members,
let's call them the bronze category,
would have access to just the comment
market.
This way,
it would be way easier to convince every
country to pass a European constitution.
In the meantime,
the idea of a United States of Europe,
it's lost a lot of support supporters.
The idea of a Europe with different
membership levels,
however,
currently enjoys a lot of stuff.
Meanwhile,
Francis brand new president is willing
to play a major role in the future of
Europe,
but what does he really stands for?
Well,
we're not answering that in this video,
but if you'd like to know more about
Emmanuel Macron,
don't forget to check out this video
that we need.
So now our question to you is,
do you think this hybrid of a federal
confederation with different men,
but categories can actually work?
Or should we keep trying?
For a federation where everyone has the
same rules,
please do let us know what you think in
the comments section below.
And by the way,
we'd like to thank Professor Oscar
Sanchez,
a constitutional expert from the
University of valid dillard for helping
us in making this video.
And if you're new to visual politic,
please do not forget to subscribe.
We publish brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday.
So do you hit that subscribe button
below so you witnessed any post and if
you liked this video,
give it a thumbs up.
And as always,
I'll see you next time
and if you'd like to hear more of my
lovely voice,
you can join us.
At reconsider the podcast,
that covers politics,
but we don't do the thinking for you
available on your favorite podcatcher.
See.